okay now all of this excuse me was all
in terms of like honestly in terms of
Cartesian stuff right well let's think
about like part of the great thing about
comics numbers is we can think about
their angles and how they relate okay so
you said axis again what's that with an
easy one okay now again remember what
does all this mean this means give me
all of the complex numbers such as their
modulus is to give me all of the complex
numbers such that when you add that
complex number in its conjugate
it'll be greater than 4 so this means
give me all the complex numbers draw
every single one of them such that when
I measure their argument
I'll get PI on three does that make
sense now now where is play on three
func of my realizes to you my imaginary
axis PI 3 is how many degrees that's 60
degrees right so keys pile 2 which is
mighty
okay so pilot 3 is not quite there you
know well it's 2/3 the way up right now
just think about this if I pick a point
here right and said ok well at that
point there that would be PI 3 that one
point is in my set and that's ok right
but it's not the only point of my set
every point earlier along that interval
to the origin also would measure pi/3
radians do you see that not only that
but actually any point going further
they're all gonna measure PI on three
okay so all of those points are in the
set it would all major PI 3 from the
positive real axis okay
all of them except for one and this is
kid'n serum what we're talking about
before I said anywhere on here on this
interval right but the problem is when
you're right there
at the origin what's the argument Oh
zero now the problem is right you can't
define the arguments here
because every angle has an equal claim
to say well I under it for zero as well
about two five how that PI they all like
if you have no magnitude campaign
modulus then you can hit any jerk you'll
still be there okay
for that reason since it could be any
argument none of them is a better choice
for the argument that any other so we
say but the argued of zero is undefined
okay so I've got a hollow circle in
indicate Yadav minutes okay our zero is
undefined
okay now for example for again I'm gonna
hijack this diagram okay this is an
equality turn equation right what if I
handed you an inequality something like
say this
okay so now I have a range of angles
that I can move through right for
instance my idea was zero that's in this
inequality checks out if this argument
were say mmm pie on six that would be
between minus point four and put them
three bar and I can get a whole bunch of
angles right so therefore I have to say
within this space I've got a whole bunch
of points that we'll all have arguments
within this range okay
biggest pound for pound for how many
degrees is that that's 45 is pi/2 is 90
so 45 degrees PI over 4 radians down in
the negative direction I've um I've made
it a dark line because because because
it's money put it in there I can't
actually have much platform but now
within this range in creating this
dotted line or excluding stomach line
and excluding the origin anywhere in
here we'll have this argument or be
within this range of arguments does that
make sense so I can make these arguments
anything I like and that means I'll have
different parts of the argued I grab
shaded ok